you're like completely opposed to this
whole operation here hi my name is Yoli
I'm a chef de cuisine and I've been
working in this industry for about 15
years name is Donna and I have been in
this industry for eight years I'm here
to rate your late night meals I hope
they don't suck I shall be sunny I'm the
only nice to meet you excited to share
this with you can't wait yeah classic
that we have components yes sweet
components gotta get the cheesy fiestas
potatoes Crunchwrap supreme with beans
sub for the meat so this is what I have
at 2:00 or 3:00 a.m. but potatoes really
are like the start the dish no one I
feel like no one really gets no one gets
some great Tupperware you have to open
if you're drunk yep thanks I'm safe true
mmm yeah right yeah good
is there anything am I supposed to put
hot sauce on it for no those and those
are fine just as this those are perfect
the way they are the potatoes are kind
of sad like the fry the next night
that's fair that's on your car but you
see like the same texture vegetarian
Crunchwrap time oh my god
it makes me happy I mean I know exactly
what I'm dealing with the inside makes
me sad cuz there's no beef stock not
late taste budget I am super convenient
it's got a very nice shape I like the
presentation I like how the crunch wrap
is folded into a little stop sign I mean
I feel the only thing that sucks about
the crunch wrap is that in the middle
tortilla it's like soggy and maybe it's
just because it's like the beans I can
honestly say I'm never gonna get it but
it's nice knowing that it's there I
would rate this like a three but I would
rate the Crunchwrap for really three and
a half out of five that's actually
pretty good
oh my god never crave Taco Bell at like
2 p.m. no no no hello hello nice to meet
you I am Swati Oh
Panera you already have a look on your
face like you hate Panera we have
cheddar broccoli soup macaroni and
cheese and a side of bread well the
presentation is in little deli cups
which is nice a nice touch too I like
that it's logoed and it's like
makes me feel a little bit more fancy
about it it's Panera open that late I
mean late enough for me a lot of color
is going on in this so this isn't soft
mushy grandma food for your late night
no shade but all the cheese is on one
side and then the noodles are very dry
on this side that's not how they usually
do it I feel like this is like I'm
curled up in bed and I didn't do
anything all day I just binge on Netflix
that sounds like my literal night almost
every night look at how creamy that soup
is it is very family does anything say
comfort like a creamy soup are you sure
you don't want any it's your love for
you and there is there you gotta love so
do you eat the baguette I do I rip it I
dip it in the soup and I eat it that's
pretty hard but that bread like scratch
my syrup on the way going down I did not
like the baguette because it's very hard
I like the broccoli cheddar more than
the mac and cheese the macaroni and
cheese is separating it's not really
doing anything for me like a 2 a 1 they
hate Panera what can I say I dunno hello
this is for you
1 2 3 yes the classic but it's not just
McDonald's you have to do like a thing
to get it ready all right so now you're
gonna take off the bun and you're gonna
put the Nuggets and the fries in the
cheeseburger mm-hmm you're gonna eat it
all like that one big stack so I came up
with it just by being lazy and wanting
to eat everything at the same lot of
work it's a lot of work but I think it's
worth it actually like the chicken in it
right hmm and it's like late at night
and you've made some questionable
decisions with your evening why am I
doing this
did you have a name for it I should come
up with a name for it I do this a lot
what strikes you about what would you
call this I don't know
the makhni the midnight nom yeah I'm a
sauce person to this
pretty dry presentation was phenomenal
only because it was very interactive I
like to assemble food it's my profession
so I like that part of it I'll give you
an extra point for that I would say I
would give this a three put the fries on
the side yeah I would just leave him
alone I'm gonna give Nate and the
McKnight four out of five for a late
night meal you're like completely
opposed to this whole operation cares
Cheers all right yeah nuggets ah all
right
chick-fil-a it's a spicy chicken deluxe
waffle fries are kind of my favorites
uh-huh feel like there's a lot of you
know ridges and stuff get a lot of
crunch of hairs maybe add like a fryer
or two in there to kind of mix it up a
little bit you don't have to yeah let me
just reach off-camera and then oh there
it is that's it
Wow all right there you go this is a sad
sad bun yeah it's a little it keeps its
structure a little bit it's really good
I have a good spice if you got some
vegetables in there yes yeah about that
the French fries that's just a you know
take it over the top these fries are sad
we are trying to be creative I like the
spiciness of it it's very mild but it's
very flavorful I wasn't ready for a
spicy either the sauce is really only
gonna get attacked for saying this the
sauces really taste like anything
he's like anything just tastes like Mayo
I would rate this a three oh it's fine I
understand
I would read this a 4.5 out of 5 I'm
gonna get fast food it's got to be the
finest don't you grant it out that over
all the meals were great surprisingly my
favorite was the chick-fil-a sandwich it
was really good the chicken was tasty
Taco Bell was for sure the best one my
least favorite was the Panera the
macaroni cheese was just not good at all
Hera closes at 9:00 we're talking
late-night I just feel like a soup is
not something that I crave I would say
Taco Bell was the spot for me all of the
meals had a good intention I would say
[Music]